in the buccaneers keep the band
together here's bruce arians talking
about his confidence in the ability of
the team to bring back its many free
agents
yeah i think the biggest thing is keep
our guys you know do what we can make
sure that we keep our guys here
and uh
and and hit a home run and free agency
just with our guys uh and not maybe an
outside guy but just keep our guys and
then uh jason will hit another home run
in the draft and we'll continue to build
this football team and uh you know we
don't have any many weak spots
if we get the guys back that we want
back and need back uh we'll just be
adding
great athletes in the draft
hey look they've got a bunch of guys who
are due to become free agents there's
the screen they've got like 31 guys
under contract going in to 2021 gronk
free agent antonio brown free agent
leonard fernett free agent chris godwin
and dominic and sue levante david shaq
barrett now they used the franchise tag
on shaq barrett so he'd be entitled to a
20 raise over that in a year where the
salary caps gonna go down to the range
of 180 million this is not going to be
easy and we've seen this before what's
the best way to screw up a super bowl
winner chris we saw that dynamic
way back when with the dallas cowboys in
the early 90s other teams start signing
away their dudes and that's what some of
these other teams may try to do but the
problem is teams aren't going to have
the cap space no that's going to be
interesting i know are they going to be
able to do it you know like can we put
that graphic back up there
um
thank you kristen
okay like the ones that i look at right
that are here that are they're at least
all right trouble to me like gronk's
coming back right i don't think there's
any way he doesn't come back yeah he's
so nice it's the only team he's playing
for right that's the only team he's
playing and antonio brown i believe is
coming back too i do i don't think
there's going to be a lot of action for
him
and i think he likes brady and being
there and everything that way too
now the other
fournette we'll see it's going to be all
about price and what he wants to do but
now godwin barrett levante david and sue
man those those are interesting ones i
mean godwin
is going to command
big money on the open market right i
mean i would think he is going to be
somewhere in that
16 17
18 million a year type of wide receiver
shaq barrett his money levante david is
going to be dancing north of 10 million
per year as far as what people are going
to want to pay him on the market and
then sue
like you've mentioned it many times he's
in that weird spot would he be willing
to come back there for half the money or
has he done he's done enough maybe to
get that type of contract that eight or
nine million dollar one year deal with
somebody else so that that to me those
last few players are the real problems
at least because they they're going to
command some big money
well and the reality is even though the
cap is going to go down there are some
teams out there that have been hoarding
and building and compiling cap space
yeah you're still going to have the
opportunity to kind of screw things up a
little bit right if they want to maybe
urban meyer took a shine to chris godwin
coaching against penn state maybe maybe
that's going to be part of the jaguars
overhaul just just pluck this guy from
the other side of the state not too far
away let's bring him to jacksonville
right because one of the things about
free agency
it's not about winning
in september through december there's an
element of it that relates to building
credibility for your team
and these are the big names these are
the guys now that you know chris goblin
if the buccaneers don't make it to the
playoffs chris goblin isn't nearly as
attractive as he is now that he's
available and you can say hey everybody
we got one of the key players from the
defending super bowl champions and also
you can feel at a certain level that
you've you've disrupted their effort to
try to repeat but the other side of this
and they may have to lose some guys i
don't know yeah like god when i want to
go like you know listen they do have
scottie miller and you got antonio brown
as a backup plan and you got tyler
johnson and exactly right so you that to
me is one where i look at and go
he could price himself out of the
buccaneer stratosphere and end up to
like one of those teams you're talking
about maybe or the new england patriots
who are going to have 90 zillion dollars
in free agency that just goes we need a
guy we got to get this kind of guy and
they're just going to pay him what he
what he deserves or what he wants and
there's going to be a veteran somewhere
who gets cut
who once he's available and people say
oh i didn't know he was going to get cut
well he'll go take the minimum to spend
a year with tom brady in tampa bay and
win a super bowl period so that's the
other side of this you can say well we
want to keep our guys
but once they start dumping contracts as
teams that are struggling to get down to
180 just throw these recognizably named
veterans overboard that's when he's
gonna be okay well we'll let chris go
because we don't want to pay him 16
million a year but we're gonna get this
guy for one year he's signing on for one
year and uh we're gonna we're gonna put
him in the lab with tom brady and we're
confident we're going to be right where
we were at the end of the 2020 season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports